breathtaking vistas and endless slopes
the dolomites in South Terrell are a
winter sport haven that can only be
described with superlatives in a matter
of minutes a lift takes you from virtnet
I'll also known as Val Gardena to the
piste nestling between the 3000 meter
high rocky peaks of land cover and a
seller group listen I know the show
instant she repeated we have one of the
most if not the most took beautiful ski
areas in the world I can is no Sheila
with all these slopes you can do more
than just traditional scheme you can go
cross-country skiing tobogganing and ice
climbing anything winter offer Europe's
largest ski area dollar mighty super ski
is connected by around 1200 kilometers
of slopes at all levels of difficulty no
wonder it attracts tourists from all
over the world
SI sono tanta kollegah me slopes our own
link and the defense along that's fun
you see that look at the scenery that's
why we come here see stop it's great the
food is go to see more another winter
sport that's gaining popularity ice
climbing on the many frozen waterfalls
like here at Tavella waterfall include
neta on the other side of the valley
mounting guide who bout more holder is
taking two tourists to climb beyond a 40
meter high frozen waterfall it's
thoroughly frozen this year and so safe
to climb who bear chose them how it's
done who shares the food is the wit that
soup put your foot in the middle missing
you I'm a bit higher in that right back
to the middle wheel in the litter and
then a bit to the left then right the
ice pick always stays in the middle of a
girl for home before the beginners get
going who bet climbs up and attaches the
safety rope to special hooks
I'm focus to start by scratching the
surface until it properly bided by
cycling up to four people can be
attached to the rope this is crucial
most beginners lose their grip on the
ice during the first few attempts the
guide clears away loose eyes to make it
safer manuela sim Bhullar from Rome
already has ice climbing experience but
it's the first time for local varina
Kozma after 15 minutes they stopped to
catch their breath isn't it took Addison
you have to look for the right spot and
test where the ice will hold you
deauville Giotto Kermit the egg entirety
I'm Frank started show nice died at
first I was afraid the ice would break
I've never done anything like this
before but it holds it's quite hard
seemly heart even for experienced
mountain climbers ice climbing is a very
different experience you have to drive
the ice picks and crampons hard into the
brittle ice the exercise quickly warms
you up despite the cold who bet Marauder
takes lots of small groups out all over
the dolomites
kindle ozcan stole one hint Alaska the
good thing is you don't even eat races
behind it always freezes differently
it's never the same as it was last year
wha want Mike anymore you always
discover new waterfalls and once that
perhaps weren't frozen before but are
frozen again this year it's great there
are numerous mountain chalets to take a
breather between climbs in winter you
can only reach them on skis or by cable
car some people come here especially for
the food sophie is a restaurant on
tsuchida at an elevation of 2400 meters
the gourmet cuisine with Italian flair
is a hit with tourists the manager
markers plea not serves traditional
regional food alongside his own
creations via for su Familia I'm try to
use local produce and some of its
organic we also serve Mediterranean
cuisine another international food
alright we make sure the basic
ingredients are as pure as possible to
keep the original flavor learden woman
angus macbadger behind you can also
climb the icefalls father up the Dharma
cliffs but it's a long way up ice
climbing is enjoying a boom here in
northern Italy many Falls remain frozen
for months a trial course is around 125
euros and you can rent the necessary
equipment just half a day will give you
a really good taste of this modern
winter sport
you